Amen. Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute
nothingness in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the
purpose of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother,
Mary, and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires, and may you,
my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to
your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your
good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels
and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit
and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. Now the first sharing we have this evening is from February the 22nd, 1925,
in which the Lord forms many paths in us in order to get us in communication with the divine will.
So Louisa said, I was thinking about the holy divine volition, and I prayed my beloved Jesus
that by his goodness he would give me the grace. Now notice it is a grace, and this is
something we need to ask as I'm reading it, that he would give me the grace to fulfill his most
holy will in everything that is in my life. And she said, you who love the holy will of God,
and you who want that this will be done, help me, assist me, and feed me this will of yours at every
instant so that nothing else may have life in me. Now there is a very short, very potent prayer
for us, and I'll use it at the end as well. Now as I was praying Louisa said, my sweet Jesus
moved in my interior, which means of course that the kingdom of God is within her, that is
Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16. And he said, my daughter, how my heart is the book says wounded,
and I always think it means touched because we have a different meaning to the word wounded.
My heart is touched or deeply touched by the prayer of one who seeks only my will. I hear the echo of
my own prayer, which I did while I was on the earth. All my prayers reduce themselves to one
single point, that the will of my father be fulfilled. Now I want to give you just two examples of that,
and one is John chapter 5, I think it's around verse 30, yes it is, my aim Jesus said,
is not to do my own will, but the will of the one who sent me. And I want to give you John
14 31. The first one is John 5 30, and the second one is John 14 31. I want the world to know that
I love the father, and therefore I do exactly as my father tells me to do. So see the connection
between divine will and obedience, that obedience is our sign of love, and Jesus is the model.
So all my prayers reduce themselves to one single point, that the will of my father be fulfilled,
both upon me and upon all creatures, which is exactly what he's teaching us, that we not only
pray that the will of God be done in us, but that should be done in the whole of humanity.
Because this mission of the divine will includes the will of God, which includes everything,
absolutely everything, it's a single point, there's no past or future in it, everything is
their creation, redemption, sanctification, everything. And therefore it is universal,
it is totally love without borders, it is salvation without borders, it is everything
without borders, and therefore it goes against the narrowness of us human beings who have lots of
borders. Okay, this is totally without borders. So he said all my prayers reduce themselves to
one single point, and that was the will of my father would be fulfilled not only in me,
but in all creatures. This was the greatest honor for me, and for the celestial father,
that I did his most holy will in everything. Now I want you to note that we're inclined to
think that obedience is a command, I mean I have to do it, and if I don't do it he'll be upset.
Jesus said it's the opposite of that, it's an honor, it's a privilege to be someone who would
carry out the will of God on earth as it is in heaven. And Jesus says the father is honored as well,
because the father is receiving the response from his creatures that he intended when he made them.
By doing the will of the eternal one always and in everything, I want you to note the always
and in everything. We don't do the will of God for an hour and then take time out,
and we don't do it for a day and take time out. You either do the will of God permanently,
because when you enter into the divine will it's permanent. He takes over. We actually surrender
totally to God, and we allow him to possess our souls so that he continues his work on earth
as he does in heaven, but he continues it on earth. And that's the fulfillment of the our father.
That I did his most holy will in everything. So by doing the will of the eternal one that's
God the father always and in everything my humanity opened the paths between the human will and the
divine which had been closed to the creature. And of course the same thing happens with us when
we enter into the divine will that opens up the way for the generations to enter into the divine
will and to allow God's will to be accomplished on the earth. So I want to give you Sam 118
verses 19 to 20, open to me the gates of holiness. I will give thanks and I will enter.
Now what are these parts of communication? And so the answer to that is in the next paragraph.
You must know he said that in creating man the divinity formed many parts of communication
between the creator and the creature. This paragraph is mostly atrocious English.
I've no idea who translated this, but what they've done is what I call transliteration,
and that is they write down what was said in the Italian, but they're not writing English.
And so the verbs and the adverbs and the nouns are all in the wrong place.
So what you're looking at and what I'm going to read is going to be slightly different because I'll
put the nouns and the adverbs in the right place. So the three powers of the soul were paths of
communication between the creator and us. The intelligence is also a path in order to understand
the divine will. Now notice he expects us to be able to understand it. The big word comprehend is
written on your page. The memory is also a path in order to remember God continuously.
Now it's very very interesting if you asked people out there on the street why were you given
the three powers of the soul they probably wouldn't be able to answer you.
The intelligence was given to us so that we would understand the divine will. The memory so that we
would continuously remember the divine will. The will is given between the intelligence and the
memory and this third path enables us to take flight into the divine will. Now we need the
intelligence to understand, we need the memory to remember and the will to take flight. So there's
your bird with its two wings. There's your eagle and if one of those wings is knocked off the eagle
will find it extremely difficult to fly. The intelligence and the memory were the support,
the defense, the strength of the path of the will. So you can see that if it is absolutely
essential to understand something and go deeper and deeper in understanding of the divine will
that studying this material is essential for us who want to enter in and live this mission of the
divine will. The intelligence and the memory were the support, the defense and the strength of the
path of the will that it might not stagger either to the right or to the left. So we start with the
three powers of the soul and then we come to all the senses. The eye is also a path in which
we might look at the beauties and the riches present in the divine will. You do that by reading
this material and by reading the scriptures and by reading the writings of the saints and the mystics.
The word is also a path by which we can receive the continuous outpouring of God's word which is
in the scriptures also in Louis' writings and the writings of the saints. So what is his word?
So let's go back a bit now. The word is a path by which we can receive the continuous outpouring
of my word and his word is Fiat. It's only one word. So this is the eternal yes to God and we have the
enormous privilege of entering into that eternal yes to God. Saint Paul says that Jesus is the yes
to God. That's fantastic. So the word is also a path and the word is my fiat he said and the goods
that all the fiat contains. So when we enter into the fiat then all that it contains is available to
us. Our hands are also paths so that by raising them in his works in my will he might come to
unifying his works with the works of the Creator. Okay the hands are paths so we unite our works
with Jesus works in the divine will and join in the works of our Creator. Our feet are paths to
follow the steps of the divine will and our hearts are paths our desires are paths our affections are
paths and to be filled with the love of the divine will and to rest in it. So you can see that
all the the powers of our being the the powers of the soul and the powers of the body are all
paths they're all communication paths with God and therefore when you read the lives of the saints for
example sometimes it is in contemplating nature that is using the eyes that the heart is touched
and the person comes to God or it's in hearing a sermon or a talk that the the heart is touched
and so the the ears have been a pathway. Sometimes it is actually in speaking the word or trying to
articulate the word for somebody else all of us who are teaching divine will can tell you that
that in trying to explain it to somebody else it's suddenly dawns on you what you're saying
which is absolutely amazing that you can prepare the material and think you've grasped it but it's
only in trying to articulate it that your own intellect grasps it at a deeper level.
So these are all paths for communicating with the divine will. See then how many paths there are
in the creature in order to come to my will if you wanted to. Now one of the things the Lord has
done here is he's caught up on us all very nicely and very quietly because some people might say
well I can't read he says well the paths are inside of you. I can't afford all these books
the paths are inside of you even if you could never read or write the paths are inside of you.
You can use the the senses of your own body and that's why sometimes it is very simple people
living a very simple life without books without education or anything that the Lord can go to and
start something great. I've just touched on a book from a little boy in Cabello in Africa he was
just a shepherd out in the field he wasn't even baptized and Jesus came to him and gave him the
messages about the end times. The child was pure and he was out among nature so the powers of his
soul were all open his senses were all open to receive the Lord and the child had no difficulty
at all and he had no difficulty recognizing Jesus or understanding him or entering into an
absolutely intelligent conversation with him and really asking Jesus very deep questions.
I was fascinated and so here even if you have no books and you have no lectures and you have
nobody to help you or anything else he says if you want to all the paths to the divine will
are inside of you if you want to. All the paths were opened he said between God and man
and this happened by virtue of our will that means by God's choice and by God's power they were
opened by him and our goods are yours. I mean the whole earth is there for us. The sun is there
for us the sea is there for us everything is there for us the sky is there for us.
After all Jesus said man was our son that means created by God himself I want to give you Sam
82 verse 6 I said you are God's all of you sons of the Most High and Jesus quoted that in John chapter
10 not only was the creature our son but he was our image so Genesis 2 1 27 tells you we were
created in the image of God and Romans 8 29 tells us that in redemption the second fiat we are made
into the image of Christ he was a work that came out of our own hands Genesis 1 27 let us make man
in our own likeness and he also came I think this is absolutely fantastic and I don't know how many
of us have really grasped this he also came out from the ardent breath of our bosom now that is the
most beautiful description of the Holy Spirit you could ever get the fiery breath of God that breath
of love that the scriptures tell us Genesis 2 7 tells us that man became a living being because
of this fiery breath of God okay Ruach Adonai the breath of God so the person to whom all these
paths were actually given is a son of God made in the image of God a work of God's own hands
and therefore a work that God was really interested in and a work that came into fullness through the
fiery breath of the Holy Spirit so it's a wonderful description there but the human will ever ungrateful
didn't want to enjoy the rights of our goods now we're the only creatures that were given free will
and I don't know maybe I'm not talking right but I think it's understandable that he didn't give
free will to everything else we behave so badly I mean if the trees and the animals and everything
had free will wouldn't we be in dire trouble I don't think they'd cooperate with us at all
so man is ever ungrateful he didn't want to enjoy the rights of our goods which we gave to it
so not wanting to do our will man did his own now notice the clear choice he didn't want
God's will he did his own and of course the disaster that followed that so you can see that
the Lord is telling us there's no other path to recovery except to come back and surrender this
human will to the divine so not wanting to do our will mandate his own and by doing his own he put
bars and fences across these paths now bars and fences are blocks now he said Jesus says that
we put bars and fences across these blocks now you go back in this the early part of this paragraph
and that means bars and fences to the intellect memory will to the eyes the ears the mouth the
heart the soul everything we ourselves clogged ourselves up with our junk
he put bars and fences across these paths he constrained himself within the miserable circle
of his own will he lost ours and he went wandering in the exile of his passion
i think it would be easier to say in the wilderness of his own passion passions because a wilderness
is a place where nothing flowers or grows he wandered in the wilderness of his own weaknesses
and under the tender birth sky tender birth is dark cloudy heavy sky loaded with storms and with
tunders now let's translate that into English that it was loaded with trials and tribulations
so really what Jesus is saying here is that the trials and the tribulations that we go through
are actually brought on by ourselves we are our own worst enemy we haven't got an enemy worse than
ourselves and he says that these trials tunders and storms he said poor child in the midst of so many
evils wanted by himself this is the result of us acting in our own will so i want to for all of
that disaster i want to give you Jeremiah 17 9 that the human heart is is perverse that's what
Jeremiah says so watch this now so each act of the human will is a bar that he puts across mine
each act of the human will is a fence that he forms to prevent the union of our wills
now i think that sentence needs to be taken off the page and really really looked at because it
means that every time i decide it's Francis's will not his then Francis is putting a block
between her and union and with god nobody else is doing it this is happening inside of me
and the communication of goods between heaven and earth is interrupted so we ourselves junk
the whole system so let me give you that in in one simple sentence we ourselves prevent ourselves
from going towards union with god and we do it through self will and stubbornness
and refusal to cooperate with the divine will so Jesus continues my humanity so now he's talking
in redemption sympathizing with and loving man with infinite love that's Jeremiah 31
verses one to three i've loved you with an everlasting love and my love is constant you see
god is immutable and god is love so he's not going to change he's not going to change because of our
behavior he remains who he is so my humanity sympathizing with and loving man with infinite love
by doing the will of my father in everything which of course is john 14 31 i kept these paths whole
still functioning and i interceded for the removal of the bars and the destruction of the
of the fences which the human will had formed so there there he is ever living to make intercession
for us Hebrews five twenty seven twenty five sorry and so my humanity that's the it there
this this text makes itself very difficult by putting it down for many many things
okay so my humanity opened the paths again for whomever wants to come into my will now notice the
once that means it is our choice it is the use of our highest faculty our will if we want to come
and if we want it then it means that we are choosing resurrection the human will brings
spiritual death we're choosing resurrection okay so my humanity opened the paths again
forever wants to come into my will to give back to him those rights which are wanted by us now
notice the wanted by us because God's will is immutable it is the same eternally and what he wanted
millennia ago he wants in millennia to come he doesn't change so he wants us to come back
in the same way as we came out from him
paths are necessary now i want to put used the expression lines of communication because we
understand lines of communication lines of communication are necessary in order to facilitate
the journey in other words we have to have various means of getting in touch with with each other
we use the phone we use the house phone the mobile we use the internet we use this and that
and the other we use the postal system we have lots of lines of communication and we find this
absolutely essential for keeping relationships alive well he's saying the same thing spiritually
as well lines of communication are necessary in order to facilitate the journey they are the means
for man to be able to make very often underline the very often there a little visit to his celestial
fatherland now the little visit to the celestial fatherland is you come back and you make an act
in his divine will i think it's lovely and it's also diffusing in his divine will and he wants you to
come very often to do it and then finally that we just simply say to him all the time i fuse
all of me in all of you all the time i don't want any break i don't want them little visits i want
to stay and these little visits to the celestial fatherland knowing how beautiful his fatherland
is and how happy people are in the heavenly fatherland the soul then begins to love the heavenly
fatherland and yearns to take possession of the divine will and therefore he lives detached
from the exile that's very awkward you should put little dots after that because that's not
actually completed the person lives detached from the world is the correct statement there
and for that i want to give you Hebrews chapter 11 verses 14 to 16 and also verses 32 to 40
now in Hebrews 11 14 to 16 and 32 to 40 the person writing the letter who is not Saint Paul by the way
we have many readers who say Saint Paul's letter to the Hebrews it's not that he didn't write it
the person who wrote this whose name we don't know has given a whole cloud of witnesses from the
Old Testament and has said these people lived detached from the world and became the great
saints of God and that's what Jesus is saying here that the more little visits we make to the
heavenly fatherland in our acts and our fusing the more we will get to love it and we will
automatically become detached from the world so these lines of communication or paths in the
creature were necessary so that very often she might rise to her true fatherland in other words
you have a house and you have an address but it's not your true address and you'll read that clearly
in Hebrews 11 their homeland was in heaven the the author says she may rise to her true fatherland
she might know the true fatherland and actually love it and as a sign that the soul is on these
paths that she loves her celestial fatherland is that placing herself on the way of our will
she makes her little visits now in all of the 17 volumes that we have studied in louisa it's
perfectly clear that louisa knows the fatherland and that she loves it and that she wants to go
there and she's been complaining since about volume three or four that she can't go there
and that when she almost gets to the gate she's sent back and she finds that extremely difficult
and then that's what the lord reminds her of here okay and this is also a sign for you
Jesus says to louisa don't you remember how many times you took the way to heaven and penetrated
into the celestial regions and after you made your little visit my will made you descend again into
the exile and since you love the fatherland the exile became ugly and almost unbearable to you
now if you read the lives of other saints besides louisa you will find that those who have had these
ecstasies and have been taken up into the heavenlies they find life on earth absolutely unbearable
afterwards louisa isn't the only one so jesus says to her your love for the fatherland now watch
this i think this is fantastic your love for the fatherland you're feeling the bitterness of living
in exile was a good sign for you that the fatherland is yours my goodness that's where you're going
in other words he's saying you're a citizen of heaven that's your destiny
so he says look it works like this also in the low world which is earth if one has a large property
he forms a path in order to go and visit it very often to enjoy it and take the goods that are in it
and while visiting it he gets to love it and he carries it in his heart on the other hand if he
doesn't form a path if he never visits his properties because without a path it's almost impenetrable
speaking in the ancient world of course he never speaks about it and this is a sign that he doesn't
love it and that he despises his own goods even though he could be rich because of his bad will
he is a poor one who lives in the most squalid misery and all i could think of was Ebenezer Scrooge
a rich man living in total misery this is why in creating man Jesus said my wisdom
wanted to form the paths between me and him why to make it easier for him to come to sanctity
and for him to have the communication of all the divine goods and also finally his entrance into
glory so notice three steps here one is the step into sanctity the second one is to have the
communication of all the divine goods coming to you it's not theory it's not in a book it's in you
coming from him and the third one is your entrance into glory this is terribly important
so let's come to march the first 1925 and we have some really important material here
on acts in the divine will and one of the things i love in these writings and you're going to find
it here because this is 1925 and electricity was really discovered and in the early part of the
20th century how Jesus uses the recent scientific discoveries in order to explain what he wants to
say to Louisa so Louisa said i was feeling very embittered because of the loss of my sweet Jesus
oh how i miss my past she said how his lovable presence used to make my poor existence happy
even in the midst of the hardest pains my poor bed was a little paradise for me
it's very interesting insight there
and so for that i want to give you sam 73 versus 25 and 26 the pain of the loss of the presence
i felt like a queen together with my beloved Jesus she said the dominator of myself oh there's
something you need to underline if you have your book with you the great thing in this life apart
in divine will is to learn how to dominate this thing i'm pointing to if i don't become a dominator
of myself then i am a slave and i want you to go to um revelation two and three and there you get
all the promises of Jesus for those who overcome themselves it's overcoming ourselves is the big
issue not overcoming anybody else and she said i was the dominator of myself i think that's fantastic
and through the continuous contact with Jesus i felt as though i was dominating his very heart
well that's true because with all the stuff that we've read in the volumes leading up to this
i mean she really knew how to pull his heart and now she said my happiness has changed
or rather every time i search for him and don't find him unhappiness surrounds me
it tears a stretch of my life away from me because Jesus alone is my life i feel more vividly the
pains of my heart exile now louis is describing very well what the world out there is experiencing
without knowing it they're experiencing this terrible absence of the lord because they have
rejected him they're experiencing themselves and their relationships and their society falling apart
because they've thrown the lord out and therefore they've thrown love and everything else with it
and so louis describes it very well here she doesn't say that she's conscious of
and making reparation for what's going on in the world but that's actually what's going on
oh how true it is that it's not the pains that render the creature unhappy but the good which is
wanted and not found that's true and while i was saying this to Jesus she said have pity on me and
do not abandon me come rise in my poor soul immersed in the bitter waters of your privation now bitter
waters in the scriptures i need to underline that it's mare m-a-or-a-h you find it in exodus
chapter 15 and it was one of the first tests that the people had in the wilderness that when
they found water the waters were bitter and god had to show moses how to put a branch of a tree
into the waters to make them sweet and that branch that moses used was a prophetic forecast
of the cross of christ the wood of the tree the cross of christ that was going to make the bitter
waters of our exile sweet with his salvation and so when louisah speaks about bitter waters here
again the people in the world who have rejected god and have accepted all kinds of aberrations and
everything they are experiencing very bitter waters and that's why you can get terrible crimes
committed and terrible wars she said this is jesus common rise in my poor soul immersed in the bitter
waters of your privation i felt my beloved god my sweet life move in my interior i see he's there
all the time stirs her luke 17 21 again and extending his arms around my neck he said to me my daughter
my daughter i looked at him she said he was coming out from a foundation of light now i want you to
write down one timothy six sixteen god lives in unapproachable light okay god is light that's one
john one five what this foundation of light that jesus is coming from is going to be a big surprise
for louisah and for you and me and a very important revelation as well he was coming out from a
foundation of light and as jesus extended his arms the light extended after him so everything was light
so if he raised his arms the light was raised as well however that light was not completely full
one could see a void within that light so this isn't the eternal light then that where he actually
comes from okay and even though a void could be seen it wasn't darkness
it was as if more filaments of light were needed in order to render the void more full
we're going somewhere very important with this and therefore the light would become more intense
you see they had learned how to make electric light bulbs and the more filaments you put in
to the bulb the more light you got the less filaments the less light it's very interesting
so the foundation of light then is the light bulb okay so it was as if more filaments of light were
needed in order to render that void more full and therefore the light more intense more strong and
more bright okay we understand the light bulbs as this at the sight of jesus louisah said i felt
myself rising again from death to life his words my daughter my daughter changed my unhappiness
instantly because being with jesus and being unhappy is impossible at the most one might be
with jesus in suffering amid the most atrocious pains but unhappy no never even more it seems that
if there is any unhappiness in the soul it flees from the presence of jesus wow the source of our
happiness and joy if you look at Galatians um i think it's 6 15 that the fruits of the spirit are
love joy peace patience kindness goodness trustworthiness meekness gentleness and self-control
and i probably left one out in other words it's all the attributes of heaven you know in our soul
therefore happy and joyful even if there is unhappiness in the soul it flees from the presence
of jesus giving place to happiness which he brings with himself so jesus as he has told us many times
already up to volume 17 he's actually the source of the attitude in heaven so where are we going
with these filaments then resuming speaking jesus said my daughter courage do not fear there's no
darkness in you because only sin is darkness while good is light now that symbology is
straight from the scriptures that darkness is there to do with the kingdom of satan and everything
that is not god and light is everything to do with god and his kingdom as well don't you know
that i have come out of a foundation of light but it was from within you that's the bit there's
here's the revelation for us so if this foundation of light is within her one quarantines 3 16 no you
not that you are the temple of the living god and that the spirit of god dwells in you
but do you know what this light is it's all the interior operating of your soul keep watching
each additional act that you do in the divine will understood is one more filament of your will
which you bind to the current of eternal light each act of the divine will is another little
filament of light that is created and that filament turns into light
because god is light and we're making acts in the divine will so acts in the divine will have to turn
into whatever god is and god is light they have to turn into whatever god is and god is love
so they turn into light and love that each filament turns into light so the more acts you do
adding more filaments the more full and the more intense and bright the light will become
in other words we become more and more and more like god therefore what you have already done
is the light that you see as the foundation of light and all the acts that we have done
since we entered into the divine will mission also is a foundation of light that we have to fill in
and make it more intense and more bright so that we become more and more and more like god
therefore what you've already done is the light that you see and what is left to do is the void
that you see but it's not anything to do with sin or badness or anything else it's simply more
work that you have to do while around the earth to reach the greatest fullness of light that you
yourself are allowed to reach by the grace of god and jesus said i will remain always in the
midst of this light now can't you see here that the lord is trying to tell us that he's on his return
in glory to the earth but god is light and he has to come into a place of light so we are creating
the path of light for him god is love we are creating the carpet for him to walk on
so we need to understand how incredibly important is the mission we've actually joined
that we have the massive privilege of preparing the way of the lord and making his path straight
look it up it's it's really it's a really a wonderful thing so and while some people will be
afraid of the second coming and they probably have good reason to be afraid as well because of their
sinfulness we have the immense joy that we are actually preparing the way of the lord
making his path straight so his path is light and love so
i will remain always in the midst of this light jesus said not only to enjoy it
but to bind the filaments of the human will to the current of the eternal light this is permanent
anything done in the divine will is permanent because god is immutable
because i am the origin i am the foundation and i also am the current of light
soon it's amazing he's everything i'm the alpha and the omega at the beginning and the end
because i am the origin i am the foundation and the current of the light but do you know
what the true light is it gets even more astonishing as we go along
true light is the truth no god is the truth john 14 6 i am the way the truth and the life
and if you want to write down some references for god is truth i want to give you john 8 32
i want to give you jute around me 32 4
john 4 23 sam 31 verse 5 and sam 33 verse 4 and i could say etc etc
true light is the truth now he has told us up to now and you'll find it also in the first verses
of john's gospel that jesus is not only the light but he is the life and he is the light of life
and he is the life of the light so the light and the truth and the life are all one
so the truth known embraced loved and put into practice by the soul is the true light
which transforms her into light itself now this really genuinely is one of the ones you need to
take out and look at he is communicating his truths about the divine will to us in these writings of
louisa and he says god is truth truth is reality as it really is
so if i call the thing i'm sitting on not a chair that's my problem because the reality is
it is a chair god is reality as it really is he is communicating to us in the writings of louisa
the true reality of how to live a divine life on the earth and he says that when we read these
truths meditate on them absorb them embrace them love them and put them into practice
that we really are experiencing all that he's saying here now as long as we're on the earth
we won't see the fullness it's actually now possible the body makes sure of that
because it's it's spirit stuff and the body has got to be laid down before the spirit is fully
released the truth known embraced loved and put into practice by the soul is the true light which
transforms her into light itself so now you know the way you know what to do and it causes new and
continuous birds of light to be placed inside and outside of her so the lord works really hard
with every movement we make in the divine will and he creates new birds of light he alone can do it
both inside and outside of us this truth forms the true life of god within the soul because god
is truth and the soul is bound to the truth and even more she possesses it that's why it is so
essential and i've been fighting this battle ever since i came into divine will that we have to
continuously study study study this material and not go fast with it because this is a journey
that we have to take and so we stay as long as we need to stay in volume 17 we don't say oh i need
to get to the other end of it no not at all this is a journey we've got to take and if you take the
journey it's fantastic so we possess the truth and god is light and she's also bound to the light
and the truth is light what he's saying is the soul is bound to god
is nourished by god with his truths that's what he's trying to say to us this is amazing
so i want to give you Ephesians 514 Revelation 22 5 1 Thessalonians 5 5
Sam 27 1 and Sam 43 3 just to let you know the whole subject of god is light and god is truth
all over the place however while i nourish the soul with truth and with light
she must keep the current of her will opened in order to receive the current of the divine
communication and for this to happen we have got to keep the will surrendered to god open means
you're surrendered to god we have got to make this ultimate absolute sacrifice that we surrender
our will to god that's what he's looking for because then he will be able to do what he needs
to do upon the earth and it's just our enormous privilege that he would use us so he gives us an
example and the example of course is the bulb otherwise it can happen the same as with an electric
current to which its own electrical characteristics are not enough the light is lacking the preparations
are needed in order to receive it in other words what he's saying is you know if you have an electric
bulb you're not going to have electric light you need to have the house wired you need to have the
the bulb connected to the power and if you switch off the light then it's no longer connected to the
power and it doesn't matter how good the bulb is and it doesn't matter how good the electrical
supply to the house is you're not going to have light it's actually that simple and that's what
he's saying about us and our will god is willing to do all of this wonder for us but we have to keep
our will connected to god it's like you switch on the light and you don't switch it off
you don't switch it off it's really fantastic so he continues with this idea that the light is
lacking and the preparations are needed in order to receive it and still the light does not reach
everybody equally but according to the light bulbs that you have now he's talking about we can get
a 40 watt or 60 watt or 100 watt or 120 watt that's what he's talking about now so all of us coming
into the divine will some of us can settle for 40 watt or 60 watt and some of us say no I'm going
the whole thing now Saint Paul if you look at Philippians chapter three he said I am running this
race to claim the prize for which Christ Jesus captured me so it really depends on us as to how
much happens to us in the divine will so if the light bulbs contain more electrical filaments the
lamps appear more full of light if they have less filaments they have less light and so on and even
if the place where the current comes from can give more light one does not receive it because the
strength of the electricity in order to receive it is lacking in the light bulb we understand the
light bulb okay therefore it takes the celestial current which wants to give as well as the human
current which wants to receive now very simply that just simply means my light bulb is connected
to the electricity and I've switched it on I want the light and according to your operating Jesus
said you will add more filaments to render more complete the light that I want to enclose on you
so this is not just a work of God in the soul it's also a work of the soul in God and I would
remind you there there's a text it's in one Corinthians chapter three I'm not sure of the verses right
now somewhere around verse 11 where Saint Paul says that Jesus alone is the foundation of our lives
but then all our actions we are building for eternal life and he says you can build with straw or
wood or you can build with silver and gold and then he says we're all going to be tested by fire
and the straw and the wood won't do well so you might get away by the skin of your teeth but you
won't have any house but the ones who have made their dwellings with gold and silver yes they
will stand testing by fire and therefore they will have mentions in heaven so Jesus is saying here
something similar that the light works the lines of communication are there but if you're not switched
on and you don't actually want all of that light you won't get it so an awful lot of it depends on
what exactly we want so let's look at March the 8th 1925. Louisa said I was saying to myself how I
wish I could go through all the ways of the eternal volition to be able to find all the acts of this
supreme will which came out of it for the good of the whole of humanity so was to be able to place
an act of my will for each act of the divine will to requite it with my love my gratitude my
thank you both for myself and in the name of my brothers so here's Louisa wanting to try and reach
all the acts in the divine will to place where I love you I adore you I praise you on them for
everybody but how could I find them she said now while I was thinking about this desiring to embrace
and to place one kiss of mine or at least one I love you of mine on each act of the of the supreme
will I felt my sweet Jesus move in my interior and a light within my mind is the way Louisa describes
this we call this infused knowledge that is knowledge is given to you you haven't read about it you
haven't studied it nobody told you it's infused so with infused knowledge the Lord communicated to
her my daughter he said do you want to go through all the acts of my will notice do you want it is
this what you want to work with do you want to know all that came out of it for the good of everybody
else well then he said come into my humanity everything is there and he said I'd like you to do it in
fact I want you to do it you must know that my humanity covered all the paths of the eternal volition
and in all the acts I found done for the good of my brothers I admitted my own to require the divine
will for its many acts done for the good of all the human generations now you'll notice that he has
inspired Louisa to ask him that she may be allowed to do something that he did in his lifetime
so he is the model whatever you do we echo it so he said this is the most legitimate act which
befitted me to do as the first honor of my celestial father and as I kept doing it now that's one of
the problems that we can have that you can start well what persevering is a different subject
he said as I kept doing it I left the deposit of my act in the divine will itself
and that they might remain always in the act of giving to my divine father this legitimate
honor which creatures do not give him and of forcing the eternal will to make peace with the
human will so I want to give you Hebrew 725 there he lives forever interceding for us because he's
acts are all alive he's going to talk about the will then as the depository the will he said
also in the creature is the deposit of all of her thoughts the book of flower says you are what
you think as a man think it so is he the will is the deposit of all her thoughts it is the deposit
of the good and of the evil that she does it is the depository of everything in every in other
words everything goes back to the will and in the early volumes of these writings when Louisa was
struggling with this and that and the other particularly when she was struggling with temptations
you heard Jesus saying to her don't put your will into it it's one thing you know to struggle
with something emotionally but don't don't want to go against the divine will and keeping your will
out of that temptation is absolutely fantastic because a thousand temptations do not add up to one sin
only the surrender of the will adds up to the sin the will is the depository of everything
it lets nothing escape which it does not deposit within itself now he said my humanity had two wills
because he was divine and human in the hypostatic union everything I did I deposited in the divine
will not only to find all the acts done by the supreme will and to requite it but to do more new
acts in the divine will in order to form in the divine will with the whole operating of my humanity
a new creation two Corinthians 5 17 so we know that particularly during that time
when he spent in the hidden life in Nazareth which was most of his life that he was creating
this new creation for us to be able to enter into it and join him and become a new creation in him
I want to give you also Galatians 6 15 so he said all of the acts that I did I wanted to form a new
creation leaving it deposited within the divine will that it might the divine will might preserve
this new creation whole ever new and beautiful without ever increasing or decreasing now you've
heard this expression over and over and over again that everything God creates he also preserves
so that no matter how many millennia of time or history passes that whatever God has made
remains as if it was just created today without ever increasing or decreasing being not subject
as much as creatures might take of it to suffering the slightest diminution just like the creation
of the heavens and the the galaxies he said and if many other things created by the divinity for the
good of the whole human family everything was left deposited in the supreme will so everything
is there when you want to go looking for something you go to the divine will everything is there
so that the divine will might preserve them always in that state in which they were created by us
as indeed it does in the same way I entrusted to the divine will the whole operating of my humanity
and this is the headline for us that we too must surrender the whole operating of our humanity
to the divine will as well so that everything I did might remain always in the act of giving
itself to creatures my operating is more than you heavens sun or stars and just as the sun which is
above your horizon does not refuse to give light to all and to give itself to each one and if the
human eye does not take it in the immensity of light it's only because the circumference of the eye
is small or rather the eye takes more light according to how sharp and good the vision is
even though the sun remains in the act of wanting to give the whole of itself we're not able to take
it all so there you have the light bulbs different levels of light bulbs some can give more light
and some less in the same way the new creation of my acts jesus said all done in the divine will
and deposited in the divine will in order to redeem and restore humanity all of these are in the
act of giving themselves to all souls all the time and much more than the sun and the stars in the
heavens they extend above the head of everyone this is universal salvation it is salvation without
borders this is grace without borders this is divine love without borders the extend above the
head of everyone so that all may take the great good that they contain as much as they want
now he's going to tell us that the sun and the moon and the stars and they can't
increase or decrease but when the soul begins to operate in the light yes it grows it expands
it becomes greater however there's a great difference between the sun that shines in the
asia heavens and the one contained in the asia heaven of my humanity
in the first one that is the sun in the sky as much as the eye strives to look in order to be
filled with light its circumference does not expand it remains always the same as it is
but with the eye of the soul the more it strives to look to cooperate to know and to love all that
my humanity has done the more it expands now the looking is contemplation with the eye of the soul
the more it enters into contemplation of all of these wonderful truths he said the more it strives
to look the more it cooperates in other words it tries to put this into practice the more it
tries to know in other words the intellect is working the more it tries to love what my humanity
has done the more it expands your soul grows and grows its capacity you may start off very small
but your capacity can become very great because jesus said that himself in john seven thirty seven
thirty nine john seven thirty seven thirty nine he says come and drink let anybody whose thirsty come
and drink he said and out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water you start off a
thirsty human being desperately needing water would you end up a fountain of living water for others
that's the way it is with him because the more we we uh work in the spirit and allow him to work
with us in the spirit the more our soul expands so the more the soul expands the more it receives
light now light is also what we call enlightenment that we grow in understanding so that's the next
thing it comprehends or it understands more because as we grow spiritually if your understanding doesn't
grow you cannot go forward your understanding has to grow and that's why it is so essential
to study all this material the more the soul expands it receives more light it understands more
and it takes more goods if you understand more of course you can take more goods because now you
begin to appreciate what's being offered and when you start it out you didn't know the value of what
you were looking at therefore it is in the soul's power to be either richer or poorer it depends
absolutely on yourself I often describe Catholics as people who starve to death outside of a bank
that they own now if somebody is so incredibly impoverished that there's no possibility of going
to a bank and getting a bit of money to buy food then you feel really sorry for them but if they
own the bank and their dying of starvation it is completely silly and this is what Jesus is telling
us here that all of this treasure is there for us all we've got to do is imbibe it take it in
contemplate it and let it give life to us so it's in the soul's power to be richer or poorer more
filled with light and heat or colder and filled with darkness it's entirely up to us now if you
want to cover the paths of the eternal volition he says in response to louisa louisa's question
enter through the door of my humanity that's why we say we fuse into your humanity divinity and will
in it you will find my divinity so in the humanity you will find the divinity and the divine will
will make present to you as though in act everything it has done everything it does and
everything it will do because we've been told a number of times that the divine will is a single
point and there's neither past nor future everything is present okay so there you will find everything
that you call past and future because you are living within the limits of time and space where
god is outside of time and space so you will find everything it has done everything it does and
everything it will do both in creation redemption and sanctification so the three fears and you will
have the contentment of being able to kiss those acts now that expression is used quite frequently
in these writings to kiss us to unite so it's very it's more important for me to say that you will be
able to unite those acts and to place your little act of love and adoration and gratitude that means
you place yours on gods that's what he means by the kiss that the two come together and you place
your little act of love and gratitude and everything on his divine act because that was what Louis asked
in the beginning you will find them all in the act of giving themselves to you in other words god
is and everything is in the divine will so if you enter into the divine will absolutely everything
is available to you and you will love them and you will take the gifts of your celestial father
a greater gift he could not give you please if you have your book with you color that one
that is the gifts the fruits and the effects of his divine will
but you will take them according to how much you cooperate and let your will be dissolved in
mind there's the bee you take mary is a very nice girl but and you don't need to finish the sentence
the boat has spoiled the very nice girl doesn't matter what you say so he's told us all of this
wonderful stuff and then he says but you can only take them according to the level at which your
your will is dissolved that means totally surrendered in mind so we might do an act in which we say
all the right things but we may not actually be able to take everything that's there because at that
time our will is not completely dissolved in him the whole issue is abandonment to the divine will
and the more of us who abandon ourselves to the divine will the quicker the lord can return
because we're creating the path of his return then for a little while louisa said i felt all of
myself in jesus and i seem to find him as though in act all the operating of the divine will for
the good of creatures i tried to follow one by one the acts of the supreme will this was the
exercise she wanted to do from the beginning and when i was doing this everything disappeared
the delirium of wanting to find my sweet jesus again made me agonize and then after many hardships
she said i felt him behind my shoulders extending his arms towards me that's the song of songs two
six and taking my hands in his with violence she said i pulled him in front and with all the bitterness
of my soul i said jesus you don't love me anymore she keeps this up at infinitum so with violence is
matthew eleven twelve the kingdom of god suffers violence and the violent take it by force
so this time louisa's had enough so she really pulls him jesus immediately giving her no time to
say anything else said my daughter what to me you say you don't love me anymore these words can be
spoken to creatures but not to jesus not to god god's love is infinite and god's love is
immutable which you see she's speaking from her emotional experience she's not actually speaking
out of theology you're saying this to the one who can never fail in love jara maya thirty one
one to three i've loved you with an everlasting love and my love is completely constant
never changes no matter what human beings do and while he was saying this she said he fixed on me
deep inside as if he wanted to find something in me which interested him very much and he kept
looking and looking that would disturb most people finally i felt another jesus come out from within
my interior all similar to the one outside i remained surprised at seeing like jesus was inside
of me and outside of me he's been telling her that for 17 volumes and until he actually
demonstrated it for her she didn't get it we're like that you see we need to experience something
finally she said i felt another jesus come out from within my interior all similar to the one
outside i remained surprised in seeing that my jesus was inside of me and outside of me and
he all goodness said tell me my daughter who formed this new life of mine in you is it not love god is
love are they not my loving chains which not only formed me within you but kept me bound and
clasped to you that is this divine union they have which you heard about in volume one
she had three experiences of divine marriage most saints are very lucky if they have one
and so that this life of mine might always grow within you i placed in you my eternal will now
notice jesus has said something extremely important there what is the purpose of the gift of the divine
will he said so that my life might always grow within you i placed in you my eternal will he's
trying to make another jesus on the earth in you and through you and it's jesus on the earth who
will welcome jesus in glory to come back and that we will all say with a worldwide one
request marinatha come lord jesus that you find that at the end of the book of revelation
and it's when the church says come and she says it completely united he'd come
it's it's absolutely wonderful and what does he find on the earth he finds himself
because he has managed to make another jesus of each one of us
so that my this life of mine might always grow within you i placed in you my eternal will
and as it is one with yours we nourish ourselves together with the same celestial food
in such a way as to make my life one with yours this john 14 verses 20 to 21 you in me and i in you
and louisa said i remained confused i didn't know what to say and for an italian that's quite
something so we'll do one more this evening this is march the 15th 1925 the divine will has the power
to form the real life of jesus in us like is this a continuation of what i've just said
and it's desperately important to get the explanation from him so louisa said i was fusing
all of myself in the holy divine volition and that is extremely important i underline it again
that we should be saying to him i fuse all of me in all of you all the time but while i was doing
this i felt all the bitterness of the privation of my sweet jesus and even though i'm almost used to
it i love that she has shifted my newtly even though i'm almost used to suffering the absence of him
yet every time i am without him it's always a new pain because of the extraordinary love she has
for him it seems to me that every time i remain without the life of my jesus jesus places a higher
degree of pain now this is a new insight for louisa jesus places a higher degree of pain
and i feel more vividly the pain of his absence you see she's growing and growing and growing so
she's experiencing within herself that terrible absence that humanity has having thrown god out
of their lives and the desperate voids they have and the awful unhappiness that they experience
so it's ever a new pain
oh how true it is that in jesus both pains and joys are ever new okay so she's making reparation for
humanity that actually doesn't want god so while i was abandoning myself in his will she said my
beloved jesus put out a hand from within my interior and the hand was all filled with light now god
is light but in his hand he also had mine but so identified with his jesus is another jesus
so identified with his that it could hardly be seen that instead of one hand there were actually
two transformed together so we're going to get the most wonderful explanation of what it means
the possession of god here and jesus sympathizing with my extreme bitterness told me my daughter the
light of my will transforms us together and forms one single life okay these two lives have fused
together to become one he said we have formed one single life the light makes its way and the heat
of the light the heat is usually the holy spirit at the heat of the light the light contains empties
and consumes everything that may prevent the identification with my life that means that the
more we want this union and the more we want this absolute abandonment to the divine will the more
the holy spirit is going to purge us of all the the stuff that needs to go because all of that junk
needs to go so the heat of that light empties and consumes everything that may prevent the
identification with my life forming one single life the problem is that jesus was able to say
can anyone convict me of sin so it's not actually possible for us to come near to forming this one
single life if there's even a shadow of sin in us therefore this is the highest spirituality you can
have therefore don't expect too many people on this planet to appreciate this or want it
and don't expect an awful lot of religious people either they won't want to pay the price
of total abandonment to god he said to her why do you afflict yourself so much
don't you feel this life of mine within you not fantastic not in sort of imagination not mystic
it's real so he's saying don't you feel the real presence within you
take note of that that's going to be extremely important when the chastisement comes
and they come to kill the church they will church will have to go through the passion
and death and resurrection just like the lord did but if we have his real presence within us
we are the temple of the living god on earth we are the tabernacles we are the living hosts
how many times jesus said to her do you not feel within yourself that my life actually working
and at other times suffering and at other times i feel you so much with myself that you're forced
to lose your emotion your breath and your mental faculties that means you're going to ecstasy
and your very nature loses its life to give place to mine
and so that you may have life again i am forced to make myself smaller within you so as to let you
re-acquire the natural motion and the use of your senses but it's always within you that i remain
now there you've got a very clear explanation as to why through all the volumes leading up to this
that you find that louisa is in this ecstatic state and then she can't even loosen her body
afterwards the priest has to bless her to loosen her body but jesus says i remain all the time
within you and it is repeated over and over in every single message that jesus comes out from within
her and don't you see that every time you see me it is from within your interior that you see me
come out so why do you fear that i might leave you if you do feel this life of mine within you
now in the next paragraph we have louisa's confession that she actually knows and does feel
the real presence within her now i i think if jesus hadn't pushed her she wouldn't have made
this confession and so louisa said am i jesus is true that i feel another life within me
which operates and suffers and moves and breathes and lays down within me but so much that i myself
of i'm able to say what happens to me many times i believe i'm about to die that is when he has taken
over completely but as soon as that that life which i feel within me makes itself smaller
withdrawing from my arms and from my head i began to live again so she knows what's going on
she just hasn't admitted it took jesus to talk about it to make her admitted
as she says but many times i don't see you and it's this seeing you that is the thorn in her side
i feel you she said but i don't see your beloved presence now you need to go to first
the first letter of peter and it's chapter one and i think it's verses five to nine
where peter says you don't see him but you love him and you you're experiencing all the grace that
he's giving to you that is the normal experience of every christian because the just person walks by
faith yes she said i feel you but i don't see your beloved presence and i fear i'm almost afraid of
that life which i feel within me now since she hasn't come across anybody who's had this experience
before to her knowledge then she's afraid of what's happening because the priests who are
guiding her they also don't know what's going on and they can't help her i'm almost afraid of that
life which i feel within me thinking who can be the one who has so much dominion within me and i feel
like a rag under his power could it be also an enemy of mine and if i want to oppose
him what he wants to do within me he makes himself so strong and imposing as to leave me not one
act of my will well that's the divine will not leaving you one act of your own will and i immediately
give him victory over me so there's the continuous surrender she's she's talking about this experience
of the divine will operating in in a very real way that she can feel within her
and how she feels about it so um jesus said my daughter only my will has this power of forming
its life in a creature nobody else can do that and certainly nobody in the hellish realm can do it
this is a work of god it is understood that the soul must have given me who knows how many times
sure proofs that she wants to live in my will we've got to stop there for a minute to reach this
point that louisa has reached jesus says we have to give him sure signs over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over again that we actually wanted he's not going to do something you
don't want it's actually very important we have to give a voluntary sacrifice of our will to his
if we want him to take over so the soul has to give sure proofs that she wants to live in my will
not in her own because each act of the human will prevents the forming of my life each act blocks
the divine will each act of the human will this is the greatest project he said that my will can
work is to have my life in the creature to have another christ on the earth its light prepares the
place for me its heat purifies and consumes everything that might be unseemly so the possession of god
is prepared for by a Torah process of purification which cannot be avoided because to quote a friend
of ours he will not come to sewerage god will only come to waters holy and therefore the preparation
that our blessed mother had for the coming of the incarnate word was that she had to be given
the gift of what we call the immaculate conception she had to be completely redeemed from the first
instance of birth otherwise the divine presence could not have stayed within her because if you
put something unholy in the presence of the divine it would burn up it would be consumed instantly
okay and so the incarnation had to have this extraordinary preparation and we have to have a
continuous process of purification to bring us to the point of this wonderful surrender as well
the heat of the divine will has to purify and consume everything that might be unseemly
and it provides me he said with the necessary elements in order to develop my life therefore
let me do that means surrender that i may accomplish everything that my will has established in you
so i want to finish now almost on the dot one minute over with just saying something that i
noticed when i was reading this preparing it today not just reading it and that is you see here that
louisa experiences this possession of god in a painful way whereas our blessed mother experienced
the possession of god in an absolutely blissful way so i want to finish there and i want to finish
with a little prayer that i made out of these writings tonight dear jesus may your divine will
come and rise in my soul you love your divine will you want it to reign in us you want your divine
will to be done by us on earth as it is done in heaven so come come then my savior helped me
assist me feed me your divine will in every instant of my life in every instant of my life
so that nothing else may have life in me so that i may do your will in everything
lord i remember your words in john five thirty where you said my aim is not to do my own will
but the will of the one who sent me i choose this also as my aim in life to do only the will
of our heavenly father and to glorify him enable me lord to give you the full sacrifice of my will
so that your will may be glorified so that you can come and reign among us
and that i would have the immense privilege of being part of your great triumphant return
to the earth amen glory be to the father and to the son and to the holy spirit as it was in the
beginning is now and ever shall be world without end amen